the human genome is now fully sequenced
all of it
whilst not identical to mine or to yours
it is a human genome fully sequenced
telomere telomere t2
well technically my hands right now
but hang on
the book of life you said
well yes at least that is how it was
first described to me when i first
learned of dna
dna is the recipe book that gets read to
make life
or is it
well anyway the book is now complete and
ready for us to read
but i have to warn you whilst it's not
quite nagger for christy as i do love a
good murder mystery it is definitely a
mystery book and likely full of many
surprises
so in this video let's talk about our
book of life what it includes and what
it doesn't and why maybe we shouldn't be
calling it the book of life
so firstly let's talk about dna how big
actually is it
twenty five thousand nine hundred and
two
hmm that sounds too small oh yeah that's
because it's my subscriber count
what i mean to say is three point zero
five five billion base pairs or three
billion fifty four million eight hundred
and fifteen thousand four hundred and
seventy two base pairs
apparently
dna is made up of dna nucleotides of
which there are four different ones
adenine thymine guanine and cytosine
atcg these are also referred to as the
bases
and then dna is double stranded a pairs
with t and c pass with g and these are
the base pairs
so given that each base is around 0.6
nanometers 3 billion of them gives 0.6
times 10 to the minus 9 times 3 times 10
to the 9 so 0.6 times 3 1.8 meters or
you can round up to 2 meters as most
people do
so you have 2 meters of dna in each of
your cells
so that's a lot of sequence to sequence
in our human cells we split this up into
23 pairs of chromosomes and by we i
suppose i mean the process of evolution
but i'm going to tell you something
we've been able to sequence dna for a
long time now
so why is it only now completed the
first human genome was initially
released 22 years ago shocking right
but then not really
they did what they could and just left
the challenging births
it's kind of like when you wash up a pan
it's easy to get most of the grease off
but there was always those bits that are
much harder to clean so you just leave
it and hope over time it will go
i am just going to point out quickly
here that i do clean my pan fully
this is merely what i observe from other
students
and well it's the same with dna
sequencing
some sequences are easier to sequence
than others
yeah literally
ah
the reason repetitive elements like this
are harder to sequence is because it's
harder to then assemble the different
sequencing breeds
and so until recently around eight
percent of the human genome hadn't been
sequenced
and this remaining a percent is what has
now been sequenced by this telomere
telomere consortium
but it wasn't just the telomeres
but also the middle of the chromosomes
the centromeric sequences
that's also challenging to sequence
because they have repetitive elements
and also because they're quite
heterochromatic so very compacted and so
the tools used to digest dna to then
sequence it doesn't work so well
so they achieved this final bit of
sequencing by using both long sequence
reads that traverse long sequences
aiding the assembly of the sequences
in combination with high fidelity
sequencing or shorter sequences as the
longer sequence reads the higher the
error rates at least at the moment
so why is it cool to sequence the genome
well so you can sequence your partner's
dna and find out if they are compatible
9.3
quite a catch i am of course taking
because whilst there are things we can
do with the genome sequence there is a
lot of things that doesn't tell us
the reference from the 1997 film kataka
being an example
so what doesn't dna tell us
well i really like the opening two lines
of this review article the genome
sequence of an organism is an
information resource unlike any
biologists have previously had access to
but the value of the genome is only as
good as its annotation
annotation that bridges the gap from the
sequence to the biology of the organism
so what is meant by annotation
well an annotation is extra information
associated with a particular point or in
this case a sequence
or in this case a video
but that's just it
extra information information that we
don't get from just sequencing the dna
so what types of things do we annotate
in the dna sequence
well a biggie are genes
sequences of dna that code for proteins
as i won't over complicate things for
now
but it may surprise you to know that
only around 1.5 percent of the dna
sequence accounts for protein coding
genes in humans
and that's not very much
almost some of the remainder are
features i've mentioned earlier such as
the telomeres and sentiments it also
includes regulatory elements that are
involved in the control of expression of
genes
more space is given to regulating the
human genes than to the genes themselves
many regulatory sequences have also now
been annotated but some of this
annotation is only possible by combining
studies of the dna sequence with other
molecular biology techniques
for example to see where different
proteins binds or the 3d structure of
the dna sequence
these further studies are necessary to
understand how the dna is read as well
as you can imagine sequencing doesn't
read dna it just well sequences it
it would be like me writing out a
passage from a chinese textbook
since i don't know chinese i can't
interpret it
we don't speak the language of dna
either it takes a complex mix of
proteins rna and small molecules to do
it
but we're learning and getting better
the thing is the genome is not
understandable as the book of life until
it has read through its translation into
physiological function
genes are blind to what they do as
indeed are proteins in higher structures
such as cells tissues and organs
this is a quote i've taken from the
music of life by dennis noble where he
argues that there is no such program of
life in dna
proteins are not the only molecules in
biological systems that determine
function
function is also dependent on the
properties of water lipids and many
other molecules that are not encoded by
genes
and what the proteins do is not
dependent on the instructions from the
genes
it is dependent on the poorly understood
chemistry of self-assembling complex
systems
they do what is chemically natural to
them
all the missing information in the book
of life is implicit in the properties of
the environment in which genes operate
these are all slightly modified quotes
i've taken from dennis's book
and they all reinforce the same idea
that we need to look at multiple
components of a cell to really
understand how life is operating
and this is best summarized in the quote
by sydney brenner i believe very
strongly that the fundamental unit the
correct level of abstraction is the cell
and not the genome
so ultimately then why should we care
about this recent advance
well of course it's a great achievement
and what it proves is that this is
possible to sequence the entire genome
not just the genes of every individual
though of course not right now given how
long and expensive it would be
but it now enables comprehensive studies
of genomic variation across the entire
human genome which we expect to further
drive future discovery in human genomic
health and disease
also as i didn't mention earlier they
used two x chromosomes here not y sorry
guys but in theory it wouldn't be hard
to also sequence it too
and then some other consequences i think
we can use from this information
is to think more about astrobiology
and yeah this has been on my mind right
now partly because i just finished
reading the contact paradox by keith
cooper
but it raises the question of what is
life is there something unique about our
dna sequence or is it possible to
generate life using a different medium
and then the other application is crispr
and gene editing building on what i said
earlier some genetic changes still
depends on the environment
a simple change may have unintended
consequences because we don't understand
the other implications of the genome
so what is the take-home
well the thing is we actually have a
good annotation of the genome at least
enough to keep me entertained and this
older chanel review was right on point
with how we go about thinking about
genome annotation being in three
categories the nucleotide level the
actual dna sequence the protein level
what proteins are included by genes and
how proteins interact with the dna
and the process levels more of the
emergent properties of a cell
and i would argue that the process
systems level is most valuable and where
we are behind on in terms of progress
but it's also the hardest to achieve
and so all in all this really is a great
advance to have the full human genome
sequence
but where the applications for
healthcare will come is from the full
sequence of the diversity of the human
genome and the interpretation of what
the sequence actually means
another area that's really important to
study for human healthcare is protein
structure and if you want to learn about
the recent advances in this then you
should watch this video here
otherwise thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening